[موسيقى]
أجنبية
إذا كنت تعتقد أنك تعرف أن الفرص السعودية هي
أنك لا
تنسى آبار النفط والثروة في الرياض
وتركز بدلاً من ذلك على الحضارات القديمة
التي نمت حول وادي الواحات التي كانت
ذات يوم مفترق طرق حيويًا على طرق تجارة البخور
المذهلة تمامًا ،
مرحبًا لولا هي متاهة  زيارة هنا تجربة جديدة
حتى بالنسبة لبعض السعوديين
لا أعتقد أنني أقدر ذلك تمامًا
كم من الثورة كل هذا
يتغير [موسيقى] هنا
لا شك في
أن التغيير
كله جيد وكل ذلك يسير في الاتجاه الصحيح
في جميع الأوقات  ليس
كذلك على الإطلاق حتى عندما أنظر إلى هذا المكان
بنظرة متشككة وربما ساخرة ،
لا يمكنك تجاهل حقيقة
أن
ملايين الأشخاص في هذا البلد
يعيشون حياة مختلفة بسبب
التغيير الذي تغير
[الموسيقى]
ولكن هذا سعودي ودعونا نكون
يمكن لأموال النفط الصادقة أن تشتري التغيير مع
النتائج الفائقة التي
أعطيتها لك ماريا ،
لذا حصلت على هذا
، ثم تتجول هكذا
وتذهب إلى هنا
ريتشارد ، عليك أن تذهب إلى
الصحراء وتنظر إلى هذا المبنى
لماذا حقًا ما يميزها هو
أنها طفولية بمعنى
أنها مجرد مرآة ولكنها مجرد
قاعة حفلات ذكية مصممة لتكون في مكان واحد
مع خلفيتها بالنسبة لي ، وهذا
ليس هو الهدف
بالنسبة لي ، فقد بنى المال شيئًا
فريدًا
من عوامل الجذب  هذا يضيف إلى ما هو موجود هنا
بدلاً من تشويهه
[موسيقى]
قبل مغادرتي ، لا أستطيع مساعدة نفسي
[ضحك]
المرح الحديث يجعلني حتى الآن
هنا من أجل الهندسة المعمارية القديمة ،
لا تجرب هذا في حرارة الصيف
القادمة  من خلال سأعود مرة
أخرى واقفًا من فضلك
لا تسمي هذه البتراء الموجودة في الأردن.
من قبل النبطيين الذين يعود تاريخهم
إلى القرن الأول قبل الميلاد وجزء من
مشروع ترميم ضخم للمملكة العربية السعودية ،
لم يتم لمس هذه الآثار منذ ما يقرب من
2000 عام
بالنسبة لعلماء الآثار ، وهذا
يعادل منجم ذهب
لذلك  ما لدينا هنا هو ما
نسميه الدائرة الحجرية الدائمة التي نعتقد أنها
منازل من العصر الحجري الحديث يعود تاريخها إلى حوالي 7000
عام ، كيف تجد بحق الجحيم
جدارًا مثل هذا ، أعني مجرد إلقاء نظرة على
هناك لن أعرف حتى أين
عليك أن تتعلم قراءة
أنماط الأنقاض أيضًا طائرة هليكوبتر ، فمن
المفيد جدًا أن تعرف أن المملكة العربية السعودية هي
واحدة من تلك الفرص الأخيرة التي
لدينا لاكتشاف شيء
جديد تمامًا حول
كيف أصبح البشر
أشخاصًا نحن اليوم
رائع حقًا ،
ما الذي تبحث عنه ، أخبرني ما لدينا
[موسيقى
] الآن بالنسبة لي مثل مجرد حفنة من
موسيقى الروك القديمة جيدًا ، لديك بعض الأشياء هناك
قليلاً من العظام ، ما الذي يحترق بعض الحيوانات
هناك كيف  هل تعرف
الهاتف إذا كنت تريد الوصول إلى اختبار
ما إذا كان يلتصق بلسانك وهو
نوع من المسام يعني أنه يحترق
بسبب العظم الصخري الصلب
[موسيقى]
إنه عالق شخص يقرصني لا
أصدق أنني ألعق  عظام حيوانات عمرها ألف عام
ولكن  بعد ذلك ستقضي الكثير من الوقت هنا
لتقول إنني لا أصدق
أن التغيير السعودي اليوم يتم ترسيخه
في الجهود المبذولة لتأسيس ماضيها الحقيقي
، أعتقد أن الكلمة التي تصف أفضل
ما رأيته هي التحول من اجتماعي
إلى تجاري إلى علم أثري إلى
الحياة اليومية يبدو أن كل شيء
يغير
قرارك ، الرياض والسعودية اليوم تنضم إلى
عالمنا الأجنبي العجيب